the person is dressed as Santa oh hell  yeah absolutely 100 the person who I  applaud you guys same dresses Santa  Clauses give them a round of applause  that's commitment we asked you to do  that and you think you're the only two  people 80 degrees you have swamps you  got to ask the very last question I hope  it's good it should be a Christmas  miracle  where's the Lowe's gift card  Did we tell you did we say how much it  was  25  how about a room key to the Four Seasons  in Dallas  [Applause]  I don't have any cash  all right come on oh here I got a 20. I  got a 20.  got a 20. 70 bucks  get yourself something there you go  something nice and lows  appreciate it for lows for Lowe's  everybody